hoping to tackle the causes of knife
crime at a grassroots level this
community football game is being played
to raise awareness in the community
about knife crime
and to remember its victims
including 16 year old damari roy who was
murdered in a knife attack last july
he was a keen footballer
his dad dwayne says these games are
important to bring people in the
community together and keep children
safe
he has two sons who often have to pass
the spot where their brother was killed
they go through the door you don't know
if they're going to come back that's the
maori didn't we're doing our best in in
the community to be honest we're trying
we're trying our best to get the use
them off the street but we need help
the governments have to help us to do
that because we can't do it on our own
last year there were nearly 47 000
serious offences involving a knife in
england and wales according to the most
recent ons statistics
and according to victim support's
national homicide service 77 percent of
young people who were murdered were
killed with a knife
everyone agrees more needs to be done to
stop young people being killed like this
but not a consensus about how to achieve
that do you put more money into
community outreach projects and youth
centres police patrols what about stop
and search on monday pretty patel
reduced restrictions on those
controversial police powers
dwayne supports stop research as an
important crime prevention tool but
there are not many others here who
welcome it
damari's friend alex is playing today to
remember him and encourage the community
to do more
let's teach them right from wrong let's
make them aware of what's on the street
also more can be done in schools with
workshops there should be more workshops
people going into schools educating
children on the dangers of carrying a
knife days like this are one way to
celebrate the memories of those lost to
knife crime and are important for the
community but everyone agrees it will
take more to bring about lasting change
madeleine ratcliffe sky news